vous le savez que je m'intéresse de plus
en plus à la mode j'aime la mode dans
tous les sens la mode la mode la mode et
ça tombe bien parce que l'image du jour
c'est une image de mode ce sont des
français qui font la queue pour aller
faire leur shopping c'est vrai que c'est
devenu art à tout le monde veut aller
dans les magasins
vous vous allez faire du shopping là
quand ça va ce week-end nous pas benhaim
honnêtement j'ai encore un peu peur
davantage est pas la pierre à ceux qui y
vont parce que je peux comprendre qu'on
ait envie un peu de sortir les jean
michel maire n'ont pas de shopping et
outillage des choses comme ça outillage
manque ouais bah oui je fais des petits
travaux chez moi donc j'ai des trucs à
acheter on ne pouvait rien acheté au
poète se faire livrer mais ça m'était
des heures de repas d abord là c'est le
bricoleur qui parle bien sûr monsieur
bricorama kelliher j ai pas encore été
et ça me donne envie comme vale j'ai un
peu peur mais ça mais faire la queue ça
mais ça m'embête ça m'embête quand même
je préfère commander sur internet pour
le moment ça vous dérange de faire la
queue non pas du tout je prendre rendez
vous savez ce qu a lyon il ya un centre
commercial qui a mis en place un petit
site internet où tu programme taux
horaire d'arrivée comme ça tape est que
ces challenges d'attentes d'accord mais
c'est là c'est vous vous allez faire
vous faites au cours de mes courses et
d'échoppés
oui je fais beaucoup de magasins masqué
qui pensent à qui suis toujours là
écoutez si on peut de la pas le droit de
les citer mais je vais souvent à
citadium même j'aime pas et qui est de
la musique tout le temps tu adoma dans
mon mari acheté par erreur une paire de
chaussures je venais d'acheter j'attende
d'ailleurs vous avez des baskets
incroyable aujourd'hui regard des jeunes
toute une série de basket
elle menace du 30 mai c'est du 30 mai
parce qu'il est pas mal taillé dans quoi
vous fais tu combien vous 97 au ces de
taille au dessus de 30 ans qu'elle s'est
laissé pousser les ongles des pieds
voilà rôle c'est à l'avait pas grave
aulas ça ça passera ça passera à
regarder regardez là que dans les
magasins durant le confinement une
question était sur toutes les lèvres
est ce que la vie d'après sera
différente eh bien on peut d'ores et
déjà répondre que probablement pas en
tous les cas c'est ce qu'on peut
conclure en voyant les images de foules
qui hier premier jour de les
confinements se sont rués devant les
magasins des images à peine croyable il
ya quelques jours encore des centaines
de français qui font la queue parfois
des heures pour pouvoir entrer dans un
magasin de prêt-à-porter ou de meubles
en kit
partout en france ces scènes se sont
répétés tout au long de la journée
laissant les témoins parfois sans voix
mais si ces comportements peuvent être
dangereux c'est surtout parce que les
distances de sécurité ne sont pas
toujours respectées et le port du masque
bien qu'obligatoires dans la plupart des
boutiques soient parfois oubliées rue
sainte catherine à bordeaux des agents
de sécurité privés sont déployés pour
informer les passants de l'obligation du
port du masque des comportements qui
inquiète de nombreux français qui
craignent une seconde vague du virus est
impossible leur confinement est ce que
ça vous énerve
voilà parce qu'être sur twitter les
vidéos des files d'attentes devant les
magasins ont beaucoup fait réagir je
vous dis je vous demande votre avis on
aura également l'avis du nombreux public
à nay qui dit donc là il ya des meufs
qui sont levés ce matin pour aller faire
la queue pour entrer dans hara vous êtes
ravagé ma parole pourquoi tout le monde
se plaint dès que pour haras c'est
logique faut bien se faire rembourser
tout ce qui va pas après deux mois de
commandes c'est drôle il ya noisy noisy
qui dit donc on fait le plus urgent le
premier jour du déconfinement c'est
d'acheter des sa part a tu vas faire ta
belle où il n'ya pas de bar ouvert il ya
pas de soirée bing et yahoo qu'il ya que
là que je vous le dis devant un célèbre
magasin de luxe des champs elysées oui
regardez
il ya des commerçants qui ont mis des
règles strictes
je vous le dis pour faire du shopping un
protocole à respecter voilà regarder
n'importe quoi les simplifie 8h à 20h le
port du masque est obligatoire
donc chaque client doivent arriver avec
un masque si jamais ils n'arrivent pas
et qu'un masque du mur on prend 1 à 2
euros qui seront entièrement déduit sur
son ticket de caisse au passage pour
arriver à zéro suite à ça s'il arrive
avec des gants qui sont de l'extérieur
il devra les enlever et utiliser de gel
hydro alcoolique ni gants seront
proposés et pourra naviguer dans le
magasin en toute sécurité
nous avons mis deux points à tous les à
m qui permet d'avoir une liste ans nous
avons équipé le magasin de protection en
pvc
quand le confort de notre personnel à
une confort de tout le monde
oui quand on vient de le voir dans un
petit magasin que tout est respecté mais
c'est assez utopique pour ce qu'il
s'agit des grandes enseignes dans les
grandes villes ou pique pardon c'est
utopique
oui avant j'appuierai au public
oui pour les grandes enseignes c'est
impossible à gérer un truc comme ça
c'est tout l'année dans la grande
enseigne qu'on vient de voir avec un z
c'est impossible de respecter les
mesures de sécurité vous l'avez bien vu
juste avant les gens ils sont dans la
queue ils sont collés à ça ils vont tous
touchés des fringues c'est ce que je
disais hier donc à ce moment-là on
n'ouvre pas les bars mais on en ouvre
les grandes enseignes qui ont peut-être
moins besoin que les petits commerces
qu'on a en france
et justement où les gens vont être
collés on vous tous touchés des fringues
ou éternuez dessus vous même les essayer
sûrement dans le magasin peut-être je
pense pas que les cabines soit ouverte
j'espère que votre phase se termine à
quelle heure il sait parler je me
demandais à bercy kelly v de v line
entendu de l'ufc que choisir
oui jean michel est passé hier devant
lens n convoyés sur les champs elysées
la grande marque tout ça mais on va le
dire oui je suis ton alors non alors on
va le dire d'autre alors on va dire
prada sont ouverts mais succi permet ce
vêtement z et bien sûr qui habille la
mode à petit prix rigoler rssi voilà oui
et donc savez qu'il ya plein de
touristes notamment chinois qui viennent
comme beaucoup d'argent mais qui sont
limités peuvent pas acheter plus de 2,5
je crois un ou deux ça qu'on niveau
d'argent parce que voilà ce que lens et
ne veut pas donner tous et ça comme ça
faut que ça soit la rareté est donc un
petit business et s'est créé il ya des
jambes dehors des jeunes qui viennent
est en fête et chinois lors de mes
commissions et c'est des petits jeunes
qui vont acheter le sac se donne après
le chinois comme ça et je lui je suis
passé bois hier et déjà une petite meute
de dix jeunes qu attendait d'avoir une
petite argent de poche pour acheter des
sacs
oui c'est du blanchiment c'est notamment
rue bayard la rue bayard et avenue
montaigne et quand on y est et ça
existait déjà et moi même j'ai été
démarché pour ça merci beaucoup c'est
des petits jeunes et donc vous avez des
marchés va écouter
soyez des marchés vous avez été
démarchés pour quoi bon pour eux mais
roger carr clown le vendeur le vendeur
de blazer aux sentiers mais moi je
comprends ce que disent mes petits
camarades mais appartement où s'est
ouvert on ne va pas jeter la pierre sur
les gens qui ont sont allés dans les
magasins là j'ai vu un peu hier une
sorte de tribunal sur qui venait oui oui
qui est qu'ils venaient un petit peu
condamnés tous les gens qui allaient
dans l'est dans les mythiques après tout
moment où ces boutiques là se sont
ouvertes où les règles sur mise en place
où les gens les respectent
et ils ont le mal il ya des distances
assuré on peut pas tenir des discours
contradictoires en disant c'est la mort
du petit commerce sur la joue au foot x
et la valeur des vendeurs c'est d'un
autre côté de ça le verre à moitié plein
en revanche nous en parlerons plus tard
dans l'émission parce que j'ai travaillé
le conducteur ce qui s'est passé sur les
quais de seine là par exemple je
désapprouve en parler mais c'est
complètement différent d'eux a pu
rassurer même si blanc mais cyril
hanouna 2008 on a une personne qui est
plus âgée qui voudraient parler et je
suis à vous dans 2 minutes oui bonsoir
madame ou c'est des copains qui m'ont
envoyé des photos de larmes de leur
corps humain où il ya des le rue
montorgueil par exemple il ya un magasin
de chaussures émane y avait du chemin
combien de dizaines de jeunes qui
faisait la queue il ne respectait
absolument pas les consignes de sécurité
or je crois moi mois d'avril pour abel
de chocolat comme ça comme ça
eh ben ils n'ont pas fouillé ils n'ont
pas foulé oui bonsoir plus vite a
précisé qu on n'en veut pas du tout aux
gens qui vont faire les magasins mais
j'en veux à ceux qui les ouvre c'est
juste ça à ceux qui y vont parce que
quand sûrement y aller à un moment donné
j'ai audi natation et magasins fermés
pas de clients c'est à ce qu'ils
respectent pas que j'en veux pas ce qui
ouvre même s'il respecterait les
magasins sont ouverts les gens d'y aller
c'est ce que vous pouvez pas vous
appelle vous avez tout fait de vos
coordonnées vous savez il ya vous
envoyer un petit dm1 voilà que vous
parlez toutes les deux mères les
chiffons en belgique justement ça va
plus loin et d'un possible d'essayer des
vêtements et même de toucher les
vêtements regardé par prudence ici les
cabines vont être fermés les essayages
se feront à la maison reste un problème
mettre de côté les vêtements touchés par
les clientes irréaliste pour cette
gérante
une telle mesure obligera fermé au bout
de dix minutes
là on nous demande de mettre de côté un
article qui aurait été touché en
quarantaine pendant 24 heures c'est
impossible on n'est pas équipé au niveau
du stock pour bloquer un article 24
heures au niveau logistique me souvenir
telle pièce là depuis douze heures celle
ci est là depuis 13h c'est là depuis 20
heures c'est tout à fait impossible
voilà bah ça l'a dit c'est tout à fait
impossible et après forcément c'est le
serpent qui se mord la queue